want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
what is the realistic price of bitcoin
and should you be investing right now
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with idea number
one
own bitcoin with anthony scaramucci we
are sitting on a little over a billion
dollars of bitcoin
um to your brother's comment uh we've
had to sell some
because
in our fund now i have a core bitcoin
fund the first trust skybridge bitcoin
fund that's a total huddling situation
i've got a lot of money in that
personally but in our flagship fund sort
of the nine billion dollars that we're
running
um we started with 400
uh would have loved to have left it but
i can't be in a situation in the
flagship fund where bitcoin is eating up
the whole fund so
i i i took some out of there we sold
some uh uh but we're gonna leave it for
right now it may trade back to 50 000. i
don't know
what i do know though
is it's likely to get to 150 000 over
the next 12 months
i'm going to stick with my earlier price
target that i shared with you on our
salt talk when you did my podcast i
think it's a hundred thousand by year
end
um and i just think it's that because
there's now
a gateway opened guys you know this
anthony a gateway opened yesterday
where an institution can now say i can
buy this
um you know if you're a vaccer or an
anti-vaxxer some of my friends said well
i'm not getting vaccinated until the fda
approves the vaccine
and so that sort of metaphorically
happened for bitcoin you got an approval
from the sec bitcoin lives
in the financial regulatory ecosystem
and it's not going anywhere and now that
portal has opened for
a sophisticated early adopting
institution to say it's okay for me to
step in the water here i'm not gonna get
fired if i own this thing idea number
two understand the visibility with
robert breedlove stock markets will
continue to exist but i think where
maybe your confusion here is
again purchasing power versus the supply
of money
so the purchasing power of money will
continue to increase the more wealth we
create through free exchange so although
there's only 21 million bitcoin it
sounds like you know this absolutely
scarce number
the amount of purchasing power it can
contain
is unlimited all right you can have an
unlimited
it's not unlimited right there is a cap
like uh there can only be whatever we
can use for bitcoin or is that not well
you can actually soft fork bitcoin and
divide it further so to your point each
bitcoin and a lot of people don't know
this this is probably important
you don't have to buy a whole bitcoin
each bitcoin is divisible into 100
million subunits called satoshi's if
ever
that divisibility were inadequate or
back to that property of money
divisibility if that were inadequate
um
liquidity to support economic activity
right if bitcoin were global money and
one satoshi were worth i don't know a
car or something
you can soft fork the code
which is to say uh
it's a simple software update let's put
it that way
to increase the divisibility of bitcoin
so that's built into the code that's
built into the code so it's bitcoin is
essentially that's one of the reasons
it's better than gold infinitely
divisible right it's only 21 million
units but you can infinitely divide it
now does that have the effect of
printing more money no and this is
another common uh
commonly misunderstood thing people
think that if you can increase the
divisibility of it then all of a sudden
you're back into inflation right but in
the problem with inflation
is the distributive effects of inflation
it's that this group is producing new
money for themselves and you're not when
you just increase the divisibility of
the money it's it's uh it's your stocks
equally stock split right
you had one share of stock now everyone
has 10. no one was diluted everyone was
just increase the divisibility of their
stock that's essentially what the soft
fork would be to bitcoin to visibility
now this
this point this is very important
because people get this confused
the more productive we become as a
global economy the more purchasing power
bitcoin can contain and that is
unlimited that is limited only by the
amount of capital we can produce
money as a
what you're gonna have to define that
then because if capital isn't money what
is it
because money is a form of capital but
let me distinguish this non-money
capital let's say all the other things
right the buildings
the stuff
the cars
the factories the equipment all of the
productive factors in an economy
non-monetary productive factors
which i'm seeing loosely as capital here
say non-money capital
money's a call option on all that right
it's denominating the value of all these
assets that are trading back and forth
but there's also this people are this
reservation demand for money people are
just holding money
as a call option on all that stuff
so another definition of money it's an
insurance policy on uncertainty the only
reason people are holding money is for
its option value we don't know what's
going to happen in the future
therefore what's the answer to
uncertainty
optionality if i have no idea what's
going to happen i want the maximum
number of options to deal with all
possible contingencies that's what money
is it's another thing money is so
if you think of money i'm sort of
talking my answer fixed supply bitcoin
over here not changing right 21 million
but this capital stock non-money
non-monetary capital growing as we trade
and produce more and more this would
imply the purchasing power per bitcoin
is growing
right it's a call option on more and
more stuff
this amount of stuff is limited by
us how much can we innovate how much can
we create
but there's no limitation on bitcoin
itself
and to the point of
a bezos or any individual actor holding
an outsized portion of the money supply
that's capitalism
what we have removed though is the
ability
for bezos because he has such a large
position in the money supply to change
the rules of the monetary network
right and that's what the fed has
effectively done it's like we hold all
the gold we're going to make the rules
bretton woods 1944. we're going to
award ourselves this perpetual free
lunch on the productive economy
for the right
of monopolizing money which sounds
asinine because it is
um
that's not possible on a bitcoin
standard so
the fixity of rules the the
unchangeableness or immutability of
rules is the bedrock of peaceful and
productive cooperation idea number three
diversify with kevin o'leary my attitude
about owning crypto and the whole sector
is
i have a discipline of diversification
i'm forced by mandate here to never have
more than five percent in any one stock
this is on the equity portfolio or never
more than 20 in any one sector and
there's 11 sectors in the s p 500. i
consider crypto to be the 12th sector it
hasn't been deemed that yet by the s p
but it's coming
and so my view is how do i get
diversification well
jordan's company hold as the symbol i'm
a shareholder is diversification it's a
series of assets on the chain so why
wouldn't i want that to me it's just i'm
investing in software productivity
software i invest in google i invest in
in microsoft why wouldn't i invest in
immutable holdings same thing they're
all the same to me and that's how i'm
going to trade it i think the value of
bitcoin will continue to increase over
time and maybe we'll beat the indices
the traditional equity and fixed income
indices and that's why you should if you
consider that have some allocation to it
which would not be a bad idea and i
don't think you have to put ever you
know bet the farm and only on bitcoin
you can own a lot of different coins
tokens and infrastructure equities as we
talked about
but you know having no allocation to it
at all in a portfolio an operating
company like mine is to say that you
don't believe in any of it and i'm
simply not that person anymore i was
very skeptical at the beginning but as
things changed and the regulators
changed and became more open to it so
did i
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there idea number four go for security
with michael saylor if we calculate the
amount of monetary energy on the network
bitcoin would be more successful than
google facebook amazon apple or
microsoft
in fact it would be more and it's you
know
much more successful than than netscape
or aol or anything from that genre
those things never got to 1 100th
right i think netscape you know at its
peak you know
was maybe 120th 130th 140th of what
we're seeing in front of us right now
and uh
the the difference really is
there is no other
uh there is no technology
and architecture
that's uh that's
appropriate to replace it the solution
to the issue of long-duration asset
or long-duration safe haven store of
value is is a very secure crypto asset
network and so bitcoin is the single
most secure
network in the world
it's the most secure database in the
world it's the most secure asset in the
world the way that you make it secure is
through the extraordinary
decentralization combined with
the way that it uh that it converts
energy into a very special specialized
sha 256 hash function
so in order to attack that network it
would take extraordinary time and effort
and energy and resources it's it's
pretty much the most secure thing we've
got in cyberspace idea number five
denominate your portfolio with anthony
pompliano financial markets have been on
an absolute tear over the last 12 months
everything seems to be going up over and
over and over again over the weekend i
was speaking at a conference and one of
the things that came up was everyone was
saying why should i go ahead and look at
other assets if my portfolio is going up
well when you start to think about a
portfolio and i asked you how did your
portfolio do over the last 12 months
which you would quote me is the nominal
rate of return you would say well the s
p 500 is up 29 over the last 12 months
so my portfolio is up 29 but if i ask
you what the real rate of return is you
would take that nominal number 29 and
you would subtract the six plus percent
inflation so actually you were doing
somewhere around
22.5
on a real return basis sounds pretty
good right no here is one of the big
things that i think most people are
going to start to wrap their heads
around is that when you are quoting the
financial return of your portfolio
you're comparing it to dollars it's a
medium of exchange it's a currency that
dollar is not a fixed amount of value
instead that dollar is actually being
devalued at a historic rate right now
that's where you get the 6
plus inflation and so what you're doing
is you're taking the asset itself the
one share the one piece of property the
one commodity and you are denominating
it in a depreciating value if the stock
market went up 29
how much of the 29 gain in the stock
market is because the dollar has been
devaluing or the stock market is
actually creating and capturing upside
value you can't really measure it and so
ultimately what i think more and more
people are going to do and what i
personally have started to do is i
denominate my entire portfolio in
bitcoin why well bitcoin is a finite
supply asset its inflation rate right
now is 1.78 that is lower than anything
else from a currency perspective that is
considered a major currency that people
would denominate their portfolios and so
if you go ahead and you compare bitcoin
and let's say the s p 500 if we
denominated over the entire lifetime
bitcoin denominated in the s p here we
go it has fallen off a cliff the s p 500
has been crashing the s p 500 is
negative when denominated in bitcoin
remember this is a fix supply asset that
is a programmatic monetary policy that
no one can manipulate what you are
looking at right here is an absolute
destruction of the s p 500 value in a
portfolio when compared with a digital
store of value we then go ahead and we
look over the last year you can see that
they're also same exact story it has
been falling very very rapidly now many
people will say why should i think about
this in terms of bitcoin being the
denomination of my portfolio it's not an
argument for you to go and take majority
of your portfolio and put it into
bitcoin rather it's the exact opposite
it is the perspective that says if i
want to maintain the purchasing power of
the digital store of value then i need
to outperform bitcoin so some people go
and they will just buy the store value
other people will actually attempt to
outperform it and so when you go ahead
and you look at that you can compare it
to the historical example of people will
look at the dollar they'll say they're
six percent inflation i have to beat six
percent to actually be able to gain more
dollars well when it comes to bitcoin
bitcoin has been going up a lot for a
long time it's up over 300 percent over
the last 12 months and it has compounded
annually for a decade at 180
180 180 compound annual growth rate for
a decade which means that if your
portfolio has not been able to achieve
180 compound annual growth rate then you
quite literally have been losing
purchasing power when measured by the
digital store value of bitcoin and so
whether you look at stocks whether you
look at commodities whether you look at
bonds or any other asset what you find
is that denominating your portfolio in
dollars continues to go up and up and up
why well this is true of every single
country that has high levels of
inflation many years there are the best
performing stock markets located in
venezuela zimbabwe argentina or other
places with high levels of inflation
because quite literally the currency in
which the stocks are denominated is
rapidly losing value it looks like the
stock prices are exploding but it's not
because necessarily the companies are
becoming more valuable it's because the
currencies are being devalued if you
were to take the stock market and
denominate it in gold as well the stock
market does not look nearly as
attractive when it starts to be
denominated in terms of an asset that is
not manipulated from a supply
perspective and so ultimately i think
that people are gonna have to wake up to
the fact that denominating your wealth
denominating your portfolio in some sort
of sound money principle looking at it
and saying what is the thing that no one
can change no one can debase no one can
take away that supply that programmatic
transparent monetary policy and that my
friends is why so many people feel like
i'm getting rich on paper but i can't
get ahead well it's because actually if
you were to look at the unofficial uh
inflation numbers it's not six percent
closer to 15 and so if you're not
delivering a 15 plus return on your
portfolio then you literally are falling
behind the unofficial inflation number
and if you were to look at bitcoin you'd
have to be delivering over 300
over the last 12 months idea number six
get rich with raul paul there's a lot of
macro guys that will be annoyingly kind
of hand wavy like if it's being adopted
at speed it's going to work and
everyone's like well what exactly can i
model that in a spreadsheet no forget
about it it's irrelevant
if you look at the rate of adoption
that's going on of the entire crypto
space
and this is my this is my true north
this is all i need to know there's one
single thing i need to know and nothing
else
so we know that it's growing at 113 a
year in terms of number of users
and we will assume that over time that
trend rate of growth falls a bit
so if it falls from this year and goes
down to 83
so that's a significant fall in the
growth rate and we saw the internet do
similar but it was at peak growth with
63 we're 113.
it gets by the end of 20 to 24 to a
billion people
and
that gets us to about three or four
billion people by 2027 28.
okay so
a blind chimp can choose a
cryptocurrency and get rich
if you look at the size of the assets
the entire crypto space as of today hit
2 trillion again i think
global equities are about 200 trillion
global bonds are like 200 trillion
um global real estate's about 100
trillion
2 trillion 200 trillion
i figure that's probably a 100x
and we all know almost all of us realize
that
all bonds all
securities all assets are going on chain
anyway
so it's probably even bigger than that
but the point being
is that you'll never ever in your entire
life ever again and ever beforehand
we're given 100x
in an asset that's already up 2 million
when you look at bitcoin
you've never been given this and you can
basically choose anything
and it will go up
so
once you do that you don't you're not
scared of making the wrong bet and it
stops you being tribal because within
that you know some of them are going to
be amazing you take the pressure off you
own a
you take some basic bets you know
bitcoin ethereum a couple of others here
and there and then you can just have a
basket of stuff and over time decide
okay i quite like that or that's getting
faster adoption
so then you start to look at like
solana is clearly getting adoption it's
clearly happening
and it's clearly happening in the price
okay so do you want to own a bit more of
that maybe
you know is polka dot getting to where
it should be don't know yet
but it's worth keeping an eye on you
know there's a there's a lot of stuff
and then so that's how i tend to deal
with it is
forget trying to model it and look for
fair values and this it's like as i said
you can be a three-year-old kid and be
given a box of names of crypto
currencies and take 10 out and you will
literally make 30 times your money over
the next 20 years the next 10 years and
idea number seven the last one before
some very special bonus clips is track
bitcoin with kathy wood we gained our
first exposure to bitcoin
in 2015 when it was a six billion dollar
network today it's about a trillion
dollar network in
a 2 trillion dollar
new asset class
uh and that that what i just said is
very important new asset class because
institutions have to look at bitcoin um
the correlation of returns uh here is
very very low relative to any other
asset base the highest correlation
between bitcoin and other assets is real
estate and that's a 0.3 that's the
highest if you look at most others very
low correlations this is what uh
institutional investors are seeking we
had a bit of a pullback this year
um
after elon
musk put a bitcoin on a tesla's balance
sheet square as well microstrategy as
well
uh and the pullback was all about
environmental is bitcoin going to um
is it consuming too much energy is it
going to create too many um
bad environmental impacts
and so we had the setback from 64 000 to
about 30 000. now we're uh closing in on
60 000 again
uh and i think partly because of our
work with square
we held a conference called the b word
and it was all about the misconceptions
around around bitcoin in particular
and environmental is one of them i
remember the same argument being made
about the internet
in the 90s in the 90s and early 2000s
that the consumption of electricity was
outrageous it was that of a a major
country i forget which one they were
using at the time and of course we can
see how in how the internet has
transformed our lives
and increased access to the emerging
markets through this little thing called
the mobile phone the computer and and
transform lives in such a good way you
can say there are side effects there but
i think everyone agrees that the
internet has been a good thing
uh bitcoin is the first private global
rules-based monetary system
that the world
has ever known
um
and uh we believe that el salvador
what's happening in el salvador
is unbelievable today because the
president decided
that el salvador was going to
step step out and uh innovate uh the
president there has given every one of
uh
his citizens
thirty dollars worth of bitcoin in a
chivo wallet now
if you look at if you look at that
country only 1.2 million
out of 4 million adults
have
banking accounts
already today
uh roughly three million have downloaded
the chivo wallet and are using it not
just to get access to that thirty
dollars but to do peer-to-peer exchange
so when you talk about the network
effect
uh we think remittances will be one of
the most important and i believe we have
numbers on that that remittances
uh account for a disproportionate amount
of the activity uh we believe emerging
markets are going to embrace
bitcoin
get away from their
many of them have corrupt
regimes and they don't trust their
monetary authorities they don't trust
their politicians generally
and so we think emerging markets are a
huge use case here
and and we believe that that use case
alone if we take away the um
four major money supplies uh that
probably aren't going to change that
much that use case alone
will add i believe the number is 200 000
if it were adopted fully throughout the
emerging markets ex china uh that that
would account for 100 000 100 to 200 000
and forgive me i don't know that which
one it is
i do know if institutions
uh were to allocate
five percent of their portfolios
globally ex china that that use case
alone would be 500 000
in addition to the 60 000
in bitcoin's price
this is much like what happened with
pension funds when it came to real
estate in the 70s
it came to emerging markets in the 80s
and 90s into the 2000s we think this is
the next iteration this is the
diversification into a completely new
asset class the first truly new asset
class since the 1600s when equities
launched
the reason that i invested in bitcoin is
because the narrative around bitcoin
being digital gold and so that really
made a lot of sense to me and that's a
store of value and the reason it's a
store of value is because it is provably
scarce
okay provably scarce is the important
thing so gold has been that thing that
is provably scarce that we have for like
5 000 years agreed is going to be the
thing that we store value in meaning
i want to buy
some gold with the money that i've
earned and then that gold sits somewhere
until 1971 this was true that gold sits
somewhere in a vault and they give me
paper receipts based on the amount of
gold that i have those paper receipts
over time people realize hey i can
actually trade these because they are as
good as gold because you could literally
take that paper receipt go to the vault
where the gold is stored change it in
for the gold so people realize whoa this
is a lot easier to trade in this paper
receipt than it is in the gold standard
so we switched to paper money which you
guys all know but it was backed by gold
then in 1971 richard nixon decides hey
we're going to go off the gold standard
and we become a fiat currency fiat means
buy decree and so now by decree we're
going to say that this money has value
but it's not actually backed by anything
other than
basically the full might of the us
government or any country's government
and this is why people have a real beef
with fiat currency
because they can print more of it now
that's definitely outside the scope of
this question but you get the idea so
i'm thinking whoa this is cool you've
got this provably scarce thing that
unlike gold which actually increases the
amount over time which means the value
of each individual piece goes down over
time
bitcoin solves that problem there's only
21 million units that will ever be
created for always and forever that's it
period full stop never a single bitcoin
never a single satoshi which is merely a
division of a bitcoin so you don't have
to buy a whole bitcoin as a side note
you can buy one satoshi which is some
tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny fraction of a
bitcoin so trust me if you've got a
dollar if it weren't for fees you'd be
able to buy
a dollar's worth of bitcoin so don't
worry you don't have to have huge
amounts of money to try this
okay so i hear this narrative that this
is provably scarce limited supply only
21 million units ever going to be made
it's not meant to replace the dollar
it's meant to be a store of value like
that gold in the vault somewhere so
instead of physical gold and a vault
somewhere i now have my bitcoin in a
vault somewhere so
that vault can be coinbase that vault
can be a ledger hardware wallet
remember when you start learning you're
learning the words so i'm throwing some
words out there that i don't expect you
to actually understand right now but
you're going to begin to learn those
which become new search terms for you in
youtube and you can go down that rabbit
hole okay so you've got your bitcoin
stored in the equivalent of a vault
somewhere
and that represents however many dollars
you used at that time to acquire so now
you're storing theoretically because
again this is a very volatile asset
you're storing value now
a reasonable question to ask is if this
is such a volatile asset why do i
consider it a store of value
there are many reasons but i'll give you
the punch line that really hit me it is
the single
fastest adopted technology in human
history
let that sink in
bitcoin
is the fastest adopted technology in all
of human history it got adopted faster
than electricity
then the telephone then mobile phones
then computers then the internet nothing
ever
has been adopted faster and when you
step back and look at i think it's 12 or
13 years that bitcoin has been around
now
as you come and zoom out all of that
volatility drops away and it is
literally up and to the right it's crazy
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want proof that bitcoin will become even
more valuable check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if you pull in your time frame to
less than a year less than 12 months and
you and you consider you know regulatory
uncertainty and market liquidity crisis
like just about anything can happen